every once in a while you come across
that movie that's supposed to be one
thing but it does one element so well
that it actually almost works against it
lilo and Stitch is one of those movies
the story is very basic an alien
experiment from another galaxy escapes
his captivity makes his way to earth and
befriends a little girl named lilo the
other aliens try to get him back while
they also learn the meaning of family
bla bla bla bla bla you can guess it
very quickly I remember I saw the
trailers for this movie and I was
thinking to myself yeah I sort of
already know this story it's kind of et
ich meets hiding a pet meets family
bonding yeah I know and I know it
so I basically avoided it but much like
the Emperor's New Groove everybody was
telling me to see it so I finally went
rented it sat down and watched it and
here's what stuck out to me the stuff
with the little girl is unbelievable
this is probably one of the best kid
characters of all time and for Disney to
accomplish that that's really something
their kid characters have ranged from
okay to incredibly annoying and
incredibly bland but this character
she's weird she's violent she's bizarre
she's emotional she's kooky she's
totally out of control
hey guess what those are kids it just so
happens she's even more stranger than
the rest of the crowd so that makes her
even more interesting god Disney finally
got this right but it doesn't just stop
there Oh what is there an evil mother or
an evil step something or other that
doesn't understand her or something no
it's actually a very believable
situation leavel has to live with her
older sister because the parents sadly
passed away but the older sister has
trouble looking out for her because
she's constantly in between jobs has to
look after a kid that's already a
handful and on top of that she's her
older sister not her parent so this is
new territory for both of them and it's
hard for them to both get used to it
there's a man from an agency who's
constantly watching them making sure
that lilo sister is a good parent but
even then he's not the bad guy he's just
doing his job and at times he sees the
tragedy of a situation too
and that's what this is a tragedy it's
just a really bad turn of events that
creates a really bad situation
it doesn't need a bad guy it doesn't
need a greedy villain it's just life
it's the first time I thought Disney
really got that and they really captured
it and for me this is bringing their
animated features to a whole new level
but sadly the film is not entirely about
that it's also about the alien and that
stuff is just okay it's not bad it's not
great it's just decent the aliens cute I
guess they have to sort of train him
like a dog and of course he learns the
meeting of family just as they learn the
meeting of family I know it I know it it
gets a few laughs and the friendship
between the two of them is relatively
strong it's just oh man I wish the movie
was just about the sister in lilo and
when you constantly had to be pulled
back to the sci-fi alien chase it sort
of disappoints you well me I should say
but like I said it's not bad it just
turns out they did one element way too
well but to be fair that's better than
having the whole film just be mediocre
and much like Tarzan I shouldn't analyze
what I wanted to be as much as what it
is
and for what it is it is really good the
animation is great like I said these two
characters are great the aliens they're
okay I mean I guess you do sort of grow
to like stitch and some of the side
characters get a few giggles the
backgrounds actually return to
watercolor backgrounds that's really
rare for Disney it was sort of a nice
comeback it was also nice that took
place in Hawaii again trying to get sort
of a different location so on the whole
it is a good movie there's just some
parts that are so much better than
others and I really would like to have
seen that explore it a little bit more
but it's still good flick and the stuff
that stands out is really fantastic
the aliens are okay but the sisters are
more than worth the price of admission